hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast cervical cancer everlasting
world health challenge it is presented
by Olivera Markovic md PhD president of
the global academy for women's health
and director at bios icon am Judy
O'Rourke of laberd's and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab routes
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want anytime you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Markovic I will
now turn the presentation over to her
Thank You Julie for your
invitation and the opportunity to share
our ideas with your respectful audience
topic then distort lecture in the
discussion during and after it we
provide benefit to all of us
I'm going to talk about spherical cancer
the only malignant disease which natural
natural history was changed by the
introduction of preventive screening and
removal of a religion this happened in
the US but as a model can be applied
worldwide and this is because I choose
to have my title clinical concern
everlasting world helped change I will
rise now to 22 just let you know about
about the agenda I will first give an
overview on the status of cervical
cancer screening globally with the
examples from two countries India and
China currently the den I will go
further out currently available
technologies for cervical cancers clinic
waho is looking for new strategies in
technologies in cervical cancer
screening then I will talk about new
approaches and new strategies based on
biomarkers and telemedicine examples and
in the last but not least is education
or general public what every woman know
about cervical cancer the cervical
cancer is second to the breast cancer
cause of women's deaths from malignant
diseases worldwide currently there are
about six hundred thousand new cervical
cancer cases each year in about three
hundred thousand died mostly from
developing world countries sadly because
cervical cancer is completely
preventable and curable if detected on
time
opening in developing countries are
well-protected with regular spins in
early removal of the suspect lesion for
example in u.s. outreach is about 80%
let me just give you India never born in
India there are 300 million women at
risk from cervical cancer from which
only 6 percent 20 million living in big
cities are protected with preventive
screening 280 million 95 percent are
left behind
about 70,000 Indian women die per year
from this disease in China there are 1.3
billion population with zero point four
billion women at risk for cervical
cancer in 2010 seventy five thousand
women were diagnosed with cervical
cancer and thirty-five thousand women
died unbelievable huge huge numbers said
for the situation in 21st century
however in the meantime Chinese
government implemented yearly cervical
cancer screening which is raising the
outreach from single digit to 25 percent
I mean I would like to give you on on an
overview about currently available
technical you can see there they are
listed
very good and after Pap test the after
baptist was introduced the healthcare
industry and health care providers
became aware the cervical cancer can be
fought successfully many new
technologies have been proposed but
three groups of tests became almost
standard the first group are test based
on psychopathology like Baptist
LDP thin prep the second group were
based on HPV detection the third group
are simplified corpus copy like V I a
visual inspection with acid and or the
IU visual inspection with logo and of
course real colposcopy bras Basah last
histology later they have been combined
with different methods of management of
patients with lesions however obviously
in spite of large investment in the
prevention of cervical cancer by
industry government a nonprofit
organization the initial enthusiasm in
the expressed outcome in advertising HPV
testing in HPV vaccines the eradication
of cervical cancer as well as with other
techniques attempts to solve the problem
provide yourself there are still below
expectation
there are still three hundred thousand
women dying from preventive cervical
cancer which is still on the rise for
ten percent per year in the world even
in the u.s. very Sarai's current rise of
cervical cancer the current regulation
and this is USPSTF spot stands for us
prevention preventive service type
fourth published in 2018 the return to
psychological screening baptist together
with HPV dual testing may bring progress
but the change of strategy towards
outcomes is actually to secure the
success
according to the most current United
Nations estimates the current world
population is seven point seven billion
one half of them are female with
exclusion of the young girls in
postmenopausal women
there are 2.6 billion women at risk for
cervical cancer every day
in spite of all current efforts as I as
I mentioned those low-cost methods and
all other methods the outreach of
preventive screening globally is at
average less than twenty twenty percent
meaning that about two billion of women
are not protected from a preventable
disease in a 21st century American
numbers are evidence-based facts they
really achieved in the u.s. a great
success in health care providers should
should be able to achieve them globally
but obviously new strategies needed
because the current approaches are not
sufficient to stop cervical cancer
constant increase of incidence
prevalence and mortality worldwide only
few developed countries are accepted
from this trend
this lecture as you can see is
emphasizing outage and special attention
is given to outreach because it import
importance then the outreach reaches the
50 and over 50% 51 percent population
the curve the curve for mortality starts
to decline make it the next slide this
is one of our favorite slides which
which compares the situation with
cervical cancer screening in the US
India and China together with a
prospective - how how to reverse the
negative trends in India and China and
you can see here right difference in
those three countries interestingly the
curve above this cone the curve about
this column shows the same phenomenon if
outreach is increased above certain
point then the the world starts to start
to happen and the this the the reversal
starts to happen the decrease of
negative tends to start to take place
what is the foundation of our new
strategy on the next slide for the next
slide this is similar similar
presentation in India where the similar
presentation in area where where those
facts are also presented about the
number order of the percentage of the
women which are screened in the results
under on the curve of mortality and
package its outreach of 51 of population
at risk
the intriguing curve of mortality by 10
percent annually both reverse to a
decreased pattern of about 4 percent
this success is achieved after about 50
years of Pap test application has shown
the the way where the end is has shown
the way where to go improve the outage
now hearing the predicate value results
in having new tools to meet such
strategy as will be discussed further it
is reasonably to expect that such
success can be achieved in less time in
in in about
for example 10-15 years after
implementation so considering the new
strategy it is a bar market-based IT and
mobile technology enabled and self and
self central collection which will all
increase the outreach particularly the
opportunity the unique opportunity that
the dish technology is giving to women
to take a sample at home and to send it
to the laboratory
this gives opportunity to win the food
is far from any medical institution to
participate in testing digital editing
combined with global networking system
can activate local points of care
connected them with medical centers
where image files will be received and
may diagnosis possible in time cooperate
when the woman is still on the premises
enabling timely diagnosing information
if necessary so we are coming to the
goal of the new strategy the goal of the
new strategy is to reverse the
increasing curve of cervical cancer
mortality about 10% if teacher what is
huge in the country severe weather where
in the countries where outreach is 50%
and more of women at risk and to start
the decreasing curve of about 40 percent
annually achieving this goal that this
girl needs general application of the
new strategy and tools to do it
I am emphasizing that it is not enough
to emphasize that outreach is the most
important outage to screenings I mean is
most important as a part of a strategy
to change the situation in the world and
to have so many lives lost from a
disease that is completely preventable
and curable and either 21st century so I
would like once just to say this new
strategy
specific aims to increase outreach then
including the accuracy with which new
composite biomarkers and to apply
telemedicine diagnosis diagnosis the
distance in reducing the cost this
technology it is using IT technology
mobile health are much cheaper and they
are shorter shortening turn out turn
between collecting specimens and
reporting the result they also reduce
the liability because Stella
cytopathology protocol can be made for
integrating the same network with other
words this is one infrastructure
independent in the infrastructure
independent technology that doesn't
doesn't depend on the place where the
woman resides
she can have a preventive screening
whenever she is located using
telemedicine now I would like to speak
try but to be more more clear to the
audience to specify on one example what
does it mean multiple technology is
among the first newcomers in this
strategy mark pop the technology is
improving the accuracy new company
composite with the new composite
biomarker called medical improving the
outreach introducing self collection of
specimens home Pap test and improve
telus cytopathology service reducing the
cost shorten turnover time between
central collection and reporting the
result lowering liability twitter della
cytopathology protocol for internet work
and in creating in our thirst after
start independent platform where every
woman regardless where she's gained is
located can be screened and very much
upset as you can see with these huge
numbers of thousands and thousands of
or some of these sisters mothers
grandmothers and aunts and wives just
died because there is no no no more
efficient ways to stop that with with so
many tools available in in the 21st
century
so mark Baptist could improve the
standard Pap test with with improve with
it it will improve all those pains or
the standard Baptist and this is a cost
outreach non accessibility and non
availability of the latino rhesus rural
community in the lack of infrastructure
in cultural sensitivity because
everything can be improved as I said
there are huge amounts of money invested
but quarry infrastructure needs dictate
to to improve to develop it needs to
have saito technologies in the small
villages of India or China this will
take a lot of time but introducing
telemedicine we have infrastructure
independent approach that will help
thousands and millions of it now new
technologies always need new strategies
always need new technologies they think
the tools I mean the new tools in new
strategies always well lead in the
technologies need new tools and I'm
going to talk about this new tools in
the next slide
markup platform technology product are
mark Baptist reagent kit markup cells
and think it then mark Bob Stella
cytopathology service in this mulmer
patella pathology service is one is ITT
HC what is a center at the point of care
which includes basic infrastructure
Apoc then medical centers a network
assistance and protocol this technology
is is a meta feedback you paste item
Obul and power baptist infrastructure
independent affordable and accessible to
be performed worldwide it is also here
is an option for self central protection
with the matically increases the
outreach on the next slide this is this
is the design of the new services it
includes novelty in in specimen
collection specimen processing specimen
evaluation and follow-up to the results
and practically related to this
practically the whole procedure is that
the woman can take a sample at home or
can come to the point of care to to have
a classic a pap smear and then this pap
smear is processed directly in the in
the in the POC
by a low trained technician and then the
selected images are sent to the Medical
Center for evaluation on the next slide
on the next slide
it is the screen cycle for healthy woman
at risk this is a network network
network for women's women who are coming
to the POC and come back without fear
from cervical cancer
now I would explain a little bit who are
those those new biomarkers and how how
it is possible so simple to do to have
such a huge benefit it is the the main
proponent of the technology is the main
segment main the main the main component
of the technologies the new biomarker
called medical it is a composite
composite biomarker biomarker providing
instant evaluation of metabolic consider
genic an HPV effect on the specimen both
cytological in HPV disease duo tested in
montes is a neighbor and with IT mobile
exchange of files and protocols for
global networking via mobile or internet
connection between the POC
in the medical centers with a protocol
for turn round of data within hours and
timely intervention the next slide is
showing start next slide is you saving
this bug and if you can see there there
are some red cells there here this is
about the mama marker is visualized as a
red deposit in the cytoplasm of normal
cells and all the abnormal cells show
this red car and it is I mean like like
like so simple simple because at the
point of care we do not need any more of
a torch we need a person who will load
the imaging technician who bill process
the slide input the slide on the
microscope and look for red cells and
then the field microscopic field which
contain red cells to beat emitted to the
professional for diagnosis it is
practically enhancing the visibility of
normal cells because all
abnormal cells are red as Markel
positive all other normal cells do not
contain any granule of red deposit and
on the next slide or the next slide now
you see only three of the normal cells
in the hog field and it may may happen
that there are not so many abnormal
cells for diagnosis may be few but with
a pair marker with a red color enhancing
the visibility those cells cannot miss
what is very important now we are coming
to product you can see here which are
those products those products are one
the first product as I list it in the
tools is the mark Pap test kit which has
reagents for market visualization in the
reagents just for morphological
screening and there is a solution so it
can be applied of on UB LBP samples and
also there is always a control side on
the next slide on the next slide if
there is a smoke it to to collect the
specimen at home home collection
specimen and this one particularly what
is now on the slide on the on the screen
is a for selling in the US or the next
slide on the next slide the the for
distribution global distribution there
is a small slope smoke it or in the
right part order of the picture which is
as I said for global distribution with
the microscopic camera or a cell phone
you can see the kit you can see the
image inside and then on the left part
of the slide microscope it read camera
or with cell phone attached to the
objective next slide please just
geomatics schematic presentation of the
route of transportation from home from
home to the lab transmittal of images by
the person sitting on the microscope in
microscope camera coming to the
evaluation place where the result is
reporting based by telephone
no news right now you like the one on
oh okay here on the next slide you can
see the same illustration I mean how new
tools
connecting point of care with expert
centers that just showing that the
distance meter can be done by by a
camera on the microscopes the upper
picture in the lower picture also the
transmitter of images can be done with a
mobile phone which is stretched embedded
on them on the microscope I'm sorry
unnormal to begin okay just another
telephone you can remove this okay and
the last slide in the in the series of
illustration of the technology is a is a
picture showing presenting telemedicine
in service and from the beginning when
the the sample comes in the in the in
the point of care where it is processed
and then through all servers and
connections to the evaluation unit at
the end come to the to the monitors and
the professional is examining the self
giving the diagnosis and send it back
electronically to the point of care so
this is one you station how this
technology works the the sample is is
received in the point-of-care just
summarizing the sample is receiving in
the point of care or it is the the smear
is done in the point of care then the
technician ro trained technician can
process the slide with with the simple
mark pop kit the procedure is made so
simple that low trained technician can
do this
so he practically stained the slide for
the visualization of the bomber in
forever mythology and then put this on
the microscope the same long train
decision you need not to be pathologist
who need not to know all the parameters
of the chromatin network and membrane
and everything else
this person should only see red cells
parameter marked by marker designate
itself and if he sees these red cells
then transmit the image because copied
image to the evaluation place and get
the result results in hours in less than
maybe two hours while the woman is still
on the premises to be treated this is
practically what I mentioned in the
beginning this is practically after this
is part is this is practically
infrastructure independent technology it
ain't there is about as I said not not
not last in not least our special
education education is the cheapest the
least expensive way how to to to get
effect in how to support all other
technologies implementation of new
strategy is unseparated provide
education of women and the shelter
providers about the cervical cancer in
this prevention mark box system includes
a textbook in stru supplements referred
further education is important and as I
said this expensive important tool for
success education of healthy women and
girls to learn how to remain healthy
education in cancer prevention to be
relieved from fear of cancer education
of women with abnormality who are very
much scared to guide them to do the
to the process and encourage them on
every step to cooperate because it is so
important and women should cooperate
throughout the process not to be to be
afraid the least everybody's afraid from
cancer but to to inspire them with
optimism to cooperate with the doctor
and succeed either in the process it is
life sparing experience and those who
survive cancer are heroes I think now
what I would like just to tell you
something else
details for the technology and
everything what I was talking on other
issues above can be found in the book
what every woman should know about
cervical cancer which is authored by two
authors by Professor Dr nanos Markovic
and myself Oliveira Markovic and this
book is a second updated an extended
edition of our book published by
Springer in 2017 and this is a monograph
type textbook with more than 500 pages
plenty of illustrations explanations and
guidances for professionals and
non-professionals audience this book is
available on the on the stringer website
and it's available on us and at the end
I would like just in the inference to
say that due to repeat the definition of
those new technologies in just this one
example that biomarkers telemedicine
power in low cost simple affordable
accessible inequitable infrastructure
independent web platform technology can
be developed into just one example that
sure will report with many when
implemented this technology will help
among those between bricks right care in
the right place at the right time for a
lower cost
just to this is both internet written
here and at the end I would like with
great pleasure to acknowledge the role
or profession dr. Leonard Marco ETS
MD PhD renowned scientist with more than
200 papers and professor of internal
medicine and oncology orders from pop
quiz as a matter of fact the director of
the whole cervical cancer program and
coordination of the whole activities so
his role is very much appreciated and at
the end I would like that to have my
address Oliveira Markovic MD PhD and my
email and I encourage everybody at
anytime to get in touch with me and ask
questions any kind of questions and I
would be very happy me and my
collaborators to respond to all of you
they do so much for your attention and I
will be probably communicating the
senior in the future goodbye now and
thank you dr. mark
formative presentation if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please send
them in via email just click on the ask
a question drop down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your questions into the box that
appears on the screen and click on the
send button our speaker will follow up
with you I would like to once again
thank dr. Markovic for her presentation
would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through February 15 2019 you'll receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event that is all for now thank
you for joining us we hope to see you
again soon
bye